imagine um mundo totalmente acessível
mundo onde todas as pessoas independente
de suas deficiências tivessem a mesma e
justa oportunidade divx enfrentar
qualquer problema mundo sem preconceitos
com tratamentos iguais e honestos mundo
pensado em todos e para o bem de todos
um drone pessoas não são corrigidas a
sair de casa por causa de possíveis maus
olhados por sua deficiência em um mundo
onde o preparo dos ambientes públicos e
privados para a inclusão dessas pessoas
fosse real mundo sem reclusão que eu
acredito que o mundo assim é possível
uma maior sonho e objetivo de vida a
ajudar a criar esse mundo real
esse mundo ideal de vocês quando estive
pensando no que poderia compartilhar
desse tema com vocês aqui hoje eu fiz
uma introspecção no meu eu interior pra
tentar entender por que eu me apaixonei
por criar um mundo melhor para pessoas
com deficiência
e aí fiz uma viagem no tempo lembrei de
algumas coisas que fazia quando ela
ainda era bem pequenininho
e aí comecei a perceber que aquele já
estava dentro de mim há algum tempo e
parte desse turbilhão de sentimentos e
sensações de resgate interno ver quando
lembrei dos meus avós sim por muito
tempo eu fui e sou menino que aprovou e
bom
esses são meus avós na foto da esquerda
é a minha vovó por parte de mãe ela foi
embora do mundo já fazem dois anos
eu amava e amo muito e faz uma falta
muito grande
ela sofria com alguns problemas físicos
conseqüência do mal de parkinson
isso fazia com que ela passasse muito
tempo na rede de balanço passar tanto
tempo lin
ela gostava muito que alguém a balançar
mas nem sempre tem alguém por perto
às vezes alguém estava trabalhando
quando podia tá em casa sempre com ela
então eu tive uma ideia bem simples mas
que mal sabia eu aquele poderia ser o
meu início nessa jornada sobre as
tecnologias assistivas eu fiz um puxador
de rede não acorda com um elástico na
parte de segurança tinha um pedaço de
pano pra ficar mais confortável e era
amarrado num pé da cama assim no quarto
dela e ela puxava e conseguisse balançar
e assim a podia lançar o quanto quisesse
na hora que quisesse e olha não é que
isso ajudava até se acalmar
inclusive aliviar alguns sintomas e esse
senhor aí na foto da direita é o vovô
por parte de pai
ele tem razão mas já fazem mais de 15
anos e desde com que ele começou a ficar
doente
eu quis muito ajudá lo e por diversas
vezes tentava contar diversas histórias
para tentar fazer com que ele se
lembrasse do passado dele de suas
memórias mas felizmente essa doença
cruel e ainda não conseguiu fazer muito
gosta de lembrar dele como eu vou
tranqüilo e sorridente e brincalhão
os óculos bonitões e estilosas e que
sempre procurava fazer o bem e ajudar o
próximo da melhor forma possível
eu costumo dizer que minha vida é feita
de muitos altos e baixos e que cada
momento desse tem um propósito me
colocar em prova
então eu cresci e apesar de ter pensado
em números rumos diferentes não tinha
outro caminho a seguir se não o da
tecnologia
apesar disto não está tão claro para mim
na na época mas a minha esposa namorada
na época quando estava nesse processo
assim decisão ela me sugeriu a melhor
praticamente me obrigou a seguir no ramo
da tecnologia da computação pois segundo
ela via meu amor pela tecnologia e tudo
que poderia criar através dela e hoje
agradeço de coração
por isso todo sabe eu também comecei a
perceber pra mim área com mais
possibilidades pra mente diversa
inquieta com a minha e mais próximo
ainda da emoção e testar infinitas
possibilidades do imaginário da infecção
que não param de rodopiar minha mente e
à medida que as condições financeiras da
minha família foram melhorando meus pais
empenhados em dar o melhor me colocavam
em cursos e mais cursos daquilo que
tanto gostava de fazer coisas coisas que
se mexiam e fazem outras coisas coisas
que hoje talvez sejam conhecidas como a
internet das coisas
comecei a trabalhar e ver vivenciar bem
de perto o que a indústria de tv vem
fazendo os seus softwares e hardwares
seus processos seus posicionamentos
contra as resoluções dos problemas dos
clientes às necessidades dos clientes e
aí passei por diversas empresas onde o
processo burocrático e mal pensado no
cliente e se fazer tecnologia me
frustaram bastante a visão a mais no
lucro e outra - no cliente
na real possibilidade de solução por
vezes eu me perguntava se era isso que
eu queria mesmo saber na época minha
esposa estava na graduação de psicologia
e eu ainda jogava quando ela chegava a
contando sobre as inúmeras inúmeras
teorias e práticas e dinâmicas que
poderão ser feitas com e para as pessoas
isso me inspirou a buscar mais valor no
meu trabalho
você for olhar para o mercado atual bem
de perto você vai ver que grande
empresas adotam metodologias e processos
mais próximos aos clientes criando uma
cultura mais próxima das pessoas
também vendo o quanto é importante
pessoas diferentes com background
diferentes especialidades conhecimentos
e até estilo de vida diferentes humanas
exatas saúde psicólogos biólogos
engenheiros cientistas todos juntos para
a inovação para chegar a um consenso
comum mais justo quando se avalia a
necessidade de um cliente pois cada um
de nós temos um ponto de vista e como já
se dizia o ditado
todo ponto de vista é a vista de um
ponto
então somos todos humanos passíveis ao
erro foi natural começa a se envolver
com assuntos da então comecei a procurar
explorar isso na faculdade
mudei de emprego pra onde podia aprender
mais sobre esse bicho chamado projetos
de inovação que tanto me encantava e me
trazem animação e participar mais
daquele montão de coisas que a empresa
moderna fazia aperto fazer coisas de
mais impacto
esse foi o trampolim para também começar
a me envolver mais com esse lado mais
ciência com pesquisa de campo com
projectos de impacto social e aí então
com tecnologia de impacto com propósito
e chegar às tecnologias assistivas e foi
nesse momento que tudo começou a fazer
mais sentido para mim pois o menino
amoroso gostava tanto de abraços fazer
um bem também pode ser despertado a
poder ajudar o próximo através da
tecnologia e como aquilo me encantava e
muitas vezes me incomodava pois eram
coisas simples que poderiam ser feitas
para melhorar a vida de uma pessoa e eu
não conseguia entender como aquilo ainda
não podia ter sido feito tanto podia ser
feito usando de recursos tecnológicos
tão facilmente acessíveis estão
disponibilizados na web como a rapidez
de processamento de imagem maps online
gps plataforma de contratação rápida de
hardwares
e tudo simples de ser usado se você já
tem um mínimo de conhecimento na área
mas até sair para um contexto mais
externo
inglaterra um texto sem muita eletrônica
envolvida ainda tinha muito o que podia
ser feito de forma simples e direta e
resolver essa opção de alguém resolver o
problema de alguém
meti a cara mergulhei no assunto e à
medida que fui me envolvendo conheci
pessoas fascinantes com lindas histórias
de superação e o amor envolvido não
fazer daquelas pessoas era massa era
recíproco e aí eu vivenciei tanta coisa
que realmente fez um puxa quanta coisa
simples a gente pode fazer para tornar
um um lugar um pouco melhor para essas
pessoas
com isso o mais encantador que isso
pareça nem todo mundo me entendia na
época aliás muita gente não entendia
quando chegava com a idéia de um projeto
com o intuito de ajudar a uma minoria de
pessoas ouvir diversas vezes que eu
poderia fazer melhor ganhar mais
dinheiro alcançar mais gente e ter mais
lucros
o famoso desistia isso não vai dar certo
eu ouvir ouvir ouvir ouvir muitas vezes
me perguntei porque tem pessoas do mundo
são tão negativas que tanta gente é tão
competitiva só pensando no lucro em se
esquece dos problemas da sociedade temos
para resolver e eu entendi que isso é
até natural
talvez seja algo que está nos
deteriorando que vem junto com esse
sangue capitalista competitivo em
demasia mas gosto mais na linha do tempo
de nossas vidas como bits de um
computador
vocês sabem como funciona e computação
três anos habitação de 0 c em uns vão
indicar um sinal de desligado o
desligado
é mais ou menos o que ocorre não se nos
coppio aquele instrumento do hospital em
que vemos que faz pipe
e indica como é que tá ali a situação da
vida de uma pessoa
então a linha do tempo das nossas vidas
são como bits vivemos oscilando entre
momentos altos momentos baixos muitas
vezes quando iniciava um projeto
totalmente estimulado pessoas chegavam à
mim e me diziam coisas negativas a esse
projeto não vai dar certo
já tem muita coisa no mercado similar
desista eu vi tudo isso eu confesso me
estimularam a continuar e aos poucos me
tirava forças para seguir adiante porque
não tirava o sentimento de que eu
realmente está fazendo um bem ao que ia
mudar a vida de uma pessoa em uma
comunidade e um país e quem sabe do
mundo mas vou contar uma coisa pra vocês
quando a gente ouve não apenas os
elogios mas também aquelas críticas que
deve com a gente
o segredo é não desistir mesmo momento
de bits 0
temos que tentar pensar com um bit um
manter o bit ligado
houve seguir em frente sem realmente
infelizmente temos que ouvir de tudo da
crítica vamos te tudo aquilo que podemos
melhorar e do elogio aquilo que temos
que melhorar ainda mais
isso foi um grande aprendizado que tive
e que é o de ouvir simplesmente ouvir às
vezes é necessário ser um mil suficiente
para ouvir e aceitar a acreditar dá
forças para o seu próximo de ser aquele
beach um momento que ele mais precisa
foi através de ouvir que eu descobri a
maravilha que é esse mundo e as coisas
boas que podemos fazer para ele foram
histórias como essas que vou contar pra
vocês que me fez levantar botar as mãos
à obra na cebit 11 para quem sabe mudar
a vida nem que seja de uma pessoa
uma das pessoas foi o washington cego
desde pequeno
desde seus quatro anos enfrentava alguns
problemas quando o assunto era jogar
futebol
é possível que ele devia se contentar
com isso mas o irmão dele um dia pegou
uma bola envolveu com a sacola de pão e
ao chutar a bola o som é produzido o
permitia jogar
eis uma simples tecnologia assistiva que
mudou o mundo de boston
outra vez ele também encontrou por o que
por ser cego
muitos não acreditavam nas suas
capacidades que por exemplo ele não
poderia andar de bicicleta mas o seu pai
por exemplo acreditou nele deu todas as
forças para que isso se tornasse
realidade
comprou uma bicicleta e logo logo com o
tempo conseguiu seguir o som do seu
coração e aprender a andar de bicicleta
às vezes a gente não tem que mudar o
mundo é mundo todo
basta recordar um de uma pessoa
acreditar nela ajudar ela dá apoio
outra história que eu quero compartilhar
com vocês é de andar na minha quando ele
saía que voltava de casa sempre tinha um
caminhão e estacionava da maneira
diferente e botava caçamba a cimpor
acima do da calçada com isso por vezes
ele se acidentava chegou uma vez a
cortar o supercílio
imagine a dificuldade dele de enfrentar
problemas como esse em seu dia a dia
em sua mobilidade sem saber o que fazer
histórias como essa foi o que me motivou
a desenvolver o projecto à noite ok está
trata de um óculos inteligente com
detecção de obstáculos para deficientes
visuais que foi decidido sobrando junto
com muitos outros amigos em vários
outros serviços com um gps aplicativos
de recomendação derrota descrição de
ambientes reconhecimento de objetos
tudo com o propósito de tornar o mundo
mais acessível para as pessoas cegas e
deste também vieram muitos outros para
pessoas com diferentes tipos de
deficiências
afinal de contas todos nós somos humanos
imperfeitos
todos nós temos um constante batalha
dentro de si mesmo para tentarmos
melhorar
para barreiras e talvez a minha maior
deficiência maior barreira que eu
enfrente que eu esteja enfrentando aqui
hoje seja barreira da comunicação
a outra pessoa que muito me fez refletir
e motivou é stephen hawking
eu não conheço ele pessoalmente só de
livros filmes televisão mas você já
imaginou se hawken em muitas outras
pessoas como ele não tivesse acesso a
sua tecnologia assistiva a que lhe
impediria a sua exposição da sua
comunicação à exposição da sua
genialidade quanto impacto ele joão não
já teve no mundo quanto impacto ou quem
já teve no mundo
quantas pessoas não poderem não podem
estar escondidas em reclusão com medo do
mundo pela falta da inclusão não pode
não podemos deixar essas pessoas de fora
precisamos evitar essa recusa ao máximo
o seu próximo que assim você vai
conseguir fazer tecnologias que
realmente impacto na vida dele
você vai conseguir ajudar seu amigo seu
companheiro uma pessoa que você conheceu
que tem um tamanho
precisamos criar tecnologias e fazer o
que for preciso que for necessário para
inclusão de todos e sabe você também
acredita naquele mundo falei no início o
mundo para todas as pessoas independente
de suas limitações humanas e suas
condições físicas motoras psíquicas
mundo para todas as pessoas todas um
mundo justo com tratamentos iguais e
honest que a inclusão não é só uma
questão de sonho e sim uma realidade
se você acredita está aqui um papel em
branco para que você também possa
começar junto comigo
esse também um bit positivo em 2011 na
vida de outras pessoas
obrigado